joining us now Oklahoma Republican
senator the gop's lead negotiator on
this potential border deal in the Senate
James Langford Senator welcome back to
Fox News
Sunday thanks good morning to you okay
so you were here about a month ago uh
you said you were getting close then you
say you're even closer now so let's talk
about the rumors uh give you a chance to
respond to some of the critics who say
they don't like what they know of this
deal there is something akin to a title
42 power that would allow um everyone at
the border to be turned away once there
was a roll average over a week of 5,000
people showing up here's Senator Ted
Cruz on that
idea this bill normalizes 5,000 people a
day coming in 5,000 people a day is over
1.8 million a
year that's called an invasion by the
way under Joe Biden we've had 9.6
million so the great Republican
compromises we're for 2third of Joe
Biden's open borders we'll let in 6
million instead of 9 million
this makes utterly no sense is that part
of the deal and how would you convince
someone like Senator Cruz to vote for
it yeah the challenge that Senator Cruz
has and a bunch of other folks is
they're still waiting to be able to read
the bill on this and this has been our
great challenge of being able to fight
through the final words to be able to
get the bill text out so people can hear
it right now there's internet rumors is
all that people are running on it would
be absolutely absurd for me to agree to
5,000 people a day this bill focuses on
getting us to zero illegal Crossings a
day there's no amnesty it increases the
number of border patrol agents it
increases Asylum officers it increases
detention beds so we can quickly detain
and then Deport individuals it ends
catch and release it focuses on
additional deportation flights out it
changes our Asylum process so that
people get a fast Asylum screening at a
higher standard and then get returned
back to their home country this is not
about letting 5,000 people in a day this
is the most misunderstood section of
this proposal let me tell you briefly
what it is the in the last 4 months we
have had 7 Days in four months we've had
s days that we had less than 5,000
people this is set up for if you have a
rush of people coming at the border the
Border closes down no one gets in this
is not this is not someone standing at
the border with a little clicker saying
I'm going to let one more in we're at
4,999 and then it has to stop it is a
shutdown of the border and everyone
actually gets turned around that's the
focus that we have right now is how do
we actually intervene in this
Administration and turn people around
not let people in so there may be some
initial measurement you get to that
rolling 5,000 in a week and then it's
zero from that point on but there is
some initial measurement our our bill
maluan is reporting that the number
would dial back then to about 3750 a day
at the border and then once you hit that
for about two weeks the gates would open
again can you confirm or deny
that yeah it's not again it's not Gates
opening this that's a misunderstanding
of the bill itself it's how many can we
process and actually Deport when you
raise the standard for people coming
across when you increase the detention
beds when you increase deportation
flights you're not letting people in and
people are thinking about how the Biden
Administration is running it now right
now the Biden Administration is allowing
for instance 1500 people a day just to
come to the ports of Entry get a work
permit and get released in the country
people coming between ports of Entry get
what's called a nose to appear and get
released in the country all of that
stops we're Focus on how many people can
we process quickly and then Deport out
of the country not release into the
country it would be absolutely absurd
for anyone to be able to propose
something to say we're just going to
slow the number of releases we're
focused on how do we actually enforce
our border and get us back to zero
people actually crossing the border
illegally every Administration has
struggled to be able to get the
authorities in place to be able to
actually enforce our border let's put
them in place so Senator miky you
brought up the idea of work permits he's
addressed this too because I know you've
said you want to set the bar higher for
getting in on Asylum so you say a lot of
people won't make it through that
initial screening process and they'll be
immediately turned away his concern is
for the people who do make it through
that right now they'd have to wait 180
days uh for a work permit he says now
that period would go away people would
get work permits immediately turning up
the electromagnet to bring people into
this
country yeah so there's two different
ways you're getting work permits if you
come to a Port of Entry right now the
body administration's just giving a work
permit the first day you walk across the
border you don't have to apply for
Asylum you don't have to qualify for
anything it's literally just show up
tell us your name and you're in the
country they're just asking that quote
unquote tell us in advance that you're
coming that's their only limitation on
it the second group is people apply for
Asylum they don't actually qualify for
Asylum they just apply for it if they
apply for it 180 days they get a work
permit these are the folks that are
driving all the blue cities crazy
because they're wandering around all of
these different cities on that we in
both of those to be able to make sure
that the only people that are getting a
work permit coming through this process
or the people that have gone through a
strenuous evaluation have been evaluated
are likely to be able to end up with
Asylum those are the individuals because
they're most likely going to stay here
that's a fraction of the people that go
through the process the vast majority of
people that actually go through this
process will be turned around and
deported we are still the United States
of America we are still open to Legal
immigration in the process and if people
are legally going through the process
and they qualify and they've gone
through the vetting inside
yes we would still continue to be able
to have those work permits but we're
stopping the free work permit pass out
at the border and the if you just sign
up and give us your name you'll get a
work permit those just end okay
President Biden spoke at this about this
last night on a campaign rally and he
said essentially if the bill were law
today it would shut down the border
right now and fix fix this whole thing
so a lot of Republicans are saying he
has things he could use now executive
powers and laws that are not being
enforced so why give him this in an
election year the cover of this deal
that you know critics say it's still
going to let a lot of people in but he
gets to take a Victory lap that he's
gotten something done yeah yeah well
it's definitely not going to let a bunch
of people in it's focused on actually
turning people around on it it is
interesting Republicans four months ago
would not give funding for Ukraine for
Israel and for our Southern border
because we demanded changes in policy so
we actually locked arms together and
said we're not going to give you money
for this we want to change in law and
now it's interesting a few months later
when we're finally get to the end
they're like oh just kidding I actually
don't want to change in law because it's
a presidential election year we all have
an oath to the Constitution and we have
a commitment to say we're going to do
whatever we can to be able to secure the
Border just as a quick for instance the
last four months we've had 50 people
across our border on the terror watch
list 50 we've had tens of thousands of
people that were declared by this
Administration a national security risk
that came across our border and were
released it is our constitutional
obligation to be able to secure our
country as fast as we can secure our
country this puts in mandatory pieces
that haven't been there in the past to
make this Administration actually
enforce the law I would tell you I don't
I don't know of anyone that believes
that if president Trump was elected he
was President right now this border
would not have this problem so the
thought that somehow President Biden can
suddenly be the pro National Security
president in the final months of this is
not believable we've had millions of
people illegally cross because he opened
up our border he literally invited the
world to be able to come and they came
that's why we have this chaos we've got
to do something now to be able to stop
it and then to be able to put new tools
that even the Trump Administration was
looking for when they were president put
those tools in place for every president
from here on out senator lenford keep us
up to date on the text thank you for
your time hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaye maanen on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights